as someone who has been a victim of
anti-semitism for both sides which one
are you more concerned about if either
and why much more concerned with the
anti-semitism of the left and not just
some on the right the reason I'm more
concerned with the anti-semitism on the
left is because I think it's closer to
the heart of left meaning that the the
anti-semites on the left people like
Keith Ellison he was almost the head of
the DNC the the the BDS movement has
become a hallmark of the campus left I
mean it's it's growing in strength on a
lot of campuses around the country and
it's being used as a rallying point it's
almost sort of an anti-western rallying
point by a lot of folks on the left
though the leftist perspective on israel
is basically that israel is bad because
israel is prosperous and rich and it is
an outpost of Western civilization in a
non-western part of the world and
therefore it's colonialist that is
really an anti Western position I don't
think it's any coincidence that when you
see students tried to pass a divestment
petition they also tried to divest at
Berkeley from the United States which
would have been weird because then they
would have had to float about a hundred
feet off the off the ground in order to
fully divest from the United States
although we have air rights I believe
but in education the I'm more worried
about that because by statistics the
movement against the toward anti-israel
position toward a Pro Hamas position is
much stronger on the Left than it is on
the right that said the growth of this
kind of alright paleo conservative
isolationism anti-israel thing has
really taken a lot of people by surprise
I do think it's minority movement inside
the conservative movement I mean even a
lot of places that are considered kind
of alt-right friendly like take right
bar where I used to work that's a very
pro-israel publication like it's it's
it's been I think horribly friendly to
to a lot of folks on they all right in a
disgusting way which is one of the
reasons I've been ripping on them for a
year and one of the reasons why I think
Milo is a terrible example for that site
but it's but Michael himself is not
anti-israel and either Breitbart and so
the the kind of growth of the specific
anti Jewish movement I think is let's
put this way I think it's more specific
on the alt right and I think it's
broader but deeper on the on the Left I
mean there's a select group of people on
the right who are really openly
anti-semitic and hate me and send me
death threats and send me memes about my
kids being gassed in gas chambers and
all this kind of crap but on the Left
what's closer to the heart of the
Democratic Party is an anti religious
bigotry and an anti-israel stands that
is much more dangerous to Jews in the
long